Can liposomal vitamin C reach the cytotoxic levels of the vitamin C in the
bloodstream that we need or even in the cells without doing it IV? I understand
such levels as 340 to 400 milligrams per deciliter. Are there guidelines for
calculated that? For example, taking 4.5 grams of liposomal vitamin C every
X hours a day. So the data that was studied with liposomal vitamin C was
really looking at how much liposomal vitamin C do you need and how it would
and the calculation of how much you need of liposomal vitamin C versus you know
regulatory and regularly ingested vitamin C. So the problem with you know
you're trying to get IV vitamin C so if you're IV vitamin C levels if you're
wanting to get let's say 25 grams how many grams of you know first of all this
years ago we talked about there wasn't very many IV centers to go to to get IV
vitamin C so people would go can I just take 25 grams of vitamin C orally when
the problem was at that time this was before liposomal vitamin C really was on
the market if you took 25 grams of vitamin C orally which you could get you know
capsules and take thousand milligram capsules which is a gram and take 25 of
those could I just do that that's a lot cheaper than going to an IV center and
there isn't any aerobic well the problem is you'd probably burn a hole in
your stomach doing that or you'd get some stomach ingestion you know in
digestion issues because of it's a scorpic acid and you could irritate your
bleeding or your stomach over time doing that secondly you're not gonna have
really good absorption you'll probably only absorb about maybe one fifth of
that so then you know with liposomal vitamin C they found that if you took about
one fourth to one fifth so about 20 to 25 percent of that you could get this
same amount of benefit of taking you know 25 so if you took 25 grams of regular
vitamin C you're only gonna absorb about five grams of it so if you took five
grams of liposomal vitamin C it would be equivalent taking 25 grams of regular
vitamin C but that's not really the calculation we're looking at yes I think there
really is an almost one to one ratio of taking liposomal vitamin C to doing IV
vitamin C the problem is is that if you want to take 25 grams of liposomal vitamin C
that could get costly too most vitamin C let me look up vitamin C that are our
our liposomal vitamin C is what's the gram dosage of a lot of the liposomal
vitamin C out there you're looking at you're looking at 1200 milligrams per
teaspoon about that so you're still taking you're taking 25 teaspoons or 20
teaspoons that you're taking almost you know almost you know a bottle or half of
the bottle depending on what size bottle you're using so it still cost you
25 still I guess it is I guess it's still way cheaper than doing an IV the
benefit that I see with liposomal 2 is that you could you know you're going to
do IV vitamin C you're doing it a couple times a week maximum with liposomal I
think there is there a benefit to you know doing it you know more often and maybe
not as high a dose but more often if you went down to the cancer clinics in
Mexico they would only give you 15 grams of liposomal of IV vitamin C but they
do it daily if you go to an IV center here or cancer clinic here that's doing
IVs you might get 25 grams you might get 50 grams you might get 75 grams but
you're only doing that once a week maybe twice a week so but it's to do 75
grams of liposomal that's like maybe maybe two bottles worth of boy that's
expensive but it's still cheaper than going to an IV and you can split it up
through the day you're gonna have as much cytotoxic benefit I think so because
remember everything has a half life in the body if you put 75 grams in the blood
over an hour log drip it's still going to be gone within a day you're not
going to have much in there maybe two days later it's going to be gone there's
not going to be enough cytotoxic dosage I still think that they're that you know
there there can be benefit to that super super super saturated dose use it in
IV but there can be even more benefit sometimes to getting up to treatment
dose on a daily basis so it really is a wonder one ratio I think with liposomal
vitamin C as far as grams goes to an IV vitamin C but now where the difference
is is you know what is the best you know super saturated dose what is the best
cytotoxic dose for a cancer patient a lot of the Mexico cancer clinics I tend
to agree with because the lower dose more frequently I know some of the
clinics up here that it stays to a higher dose less frequent maybe there's
benefit to both I don't know you know what date is out there showing the
difference between those Dr. Connors may I comment on that please I was I was
going to do the Reardon protocol which is basically they start you out at 12
grams then to 25 then to 50 grams and then during the off days they have you
take one gram of liposomal every four hours and somehow and then they measure
your blood for weak eat hours yeah that's my understanding yes and then they
they they take your blood to see if you're at the 340 the 400 milligram for
deciliter concentration and somehow it's there's some cumulative effect so they
can actually do it twice a week and have that work out I don't know I've never
done it but I'm gonna try it beginning tomorrow okay so see that kind of fits with
my light of thinking so they're giving you the IB to kind of get you get your
tissues saturated and then they're have you followed up doing daily life was
almost so that makes sense it even makes more sense if they're objectively
measuring it and I was thinking that you know it might be cheap because I I can get
with the announce I can get 4.5 grams of liposomal vitamin C orally and I can do
that like four times a day or whatever it is and I was even thinking of having
them measure the density in my blood just on liposomal alone and see what we can
achieve just as a experiment because I couldn't find you're the first person that
said the one the one ratio I looked all over to find some kind of answer to
that and I couldn't find one well I think it's a pretty close to what the one
ratio IB to liposomal it's not IB to taking a vitamin C a scorpic acid pill
understood so okay thank you so much it really is based on how much you're
absorbing so obviously when you do an IV you're getting it directly into blood
straight if you're taking it orally how much are you actually absorbing but
liposomal you're really absorbing the majority of it so that's the benefit of the
liposomal okay thank you